just been chasing these hoes really uh
no offense hoes just trying to meet a
good lady
you know i see some of y'all got one
good on you some lovely ladies here
tonight uh
it's tough you got to have money these
days to get a woman you know and i don't
blame you ladies
who wants to [ __ ] some poor guy that's
nasty you get done banging you're just
laying there all poor
so can i get you a towel that won't
match any of the other towels
what about some chips i want a split bag
of chips with daddy
some chips baby won't calorie up after
that bang wild cat
you gotta have money to get the ladies
man you gotta have nice [ __ ]
i don't have nice [ __ ] i got the other
[ __ ]
i don't have a nice apartment that's how
i cheat right i put all my nicest stuff
right by the door right so it looks nice
when you come in
yeah just step over that new toaster
nice just set your purse by that
sopranos box set
haters welcome
i don't have a nice car i have that car
we act like you don't remember where you
parked but you're standing right next to
your car
when nobody's looking you [ __ ] get in
you escape
it looks like you're stealing your own
car
you tell your friends it's a rental
they're like they're renting 97 accords
to people
like yeah i'm just driving it for
charity actually yeah
yeah every time i florida blind boy can
see for a second
so he gets that pop you know so i get a
lot of speeding tickets you know for
his little dark ass
no offense if anybody's blind either
and my friend maurice is blind and he
said it ain't that bad in there
but you gotta have money to get the
ladies if you don't have money you gotta
have other money
drugs especially in l.a man that's where
i live
now dude them girls out there a bunch of
coke ghosts that's what i call them
coke ghost baby because they're
invisible they don't answer your calls
they don't answer your text
but you break out a little bag of snow
cane they [ __ ] show up out of thin
air like blue
blue
then they're angry when you want to get
them in the sheets i'm like [ __ ] you're
a ghost
this your natural attire now come to
daddy
and if you don't have money or drugs you
got to be yourself [ __ ] that man
last thing i'm doing is being myself not
on my watch
what am i going to say to a girl hey my
name is theo mostly i just netflix and
keep my hopes up
[ __ ] you'll be alone forever
[Applause]
but these days you don't have to be
yourself really because they have the
internet right
the internet you can be whatever you
want you could be a pineapple you could
be dead
you could be whatever you want man i met
a girl recently online right i hit her
up
i said let's get some coffee so she
write me back she said coffee's boring
didn't you read my profile i'm
adventurous
i want to go skydiving on our first date
and nowhere in my budget is there
skydiving for unknown [ __ ] money
that [ __ ] ain't hitting my bottom line i
keep unknown [ __ ] at sea level
so i wrote her back i said well listen
here fancy
i happen to live on the 11th floor of my
building
won't you come over here i'll assist you
off the balcony
in a windbreaker if you're still feeling
all adventurous down on the flower beds
i'll get your newly crippled ass of
coffee then
but the caffeine ain't going to save
your legs you're greedy little gremlin
and now i'm angry now i'm angry at a
woman
that i've never even met thanks internet
do you know what it's like to be angry
at [ __ ] you don't even know
my buddy sherman's like what's wrong i'm
like this [ __ ] she's like hey i'm like
i don't know
invisible [ __ ] sherman
she's a skydiver let's wait for her ass
well how will we know when she gets here
if she's invisible i don't know
tweets you feel [ __ ] in the air that's
probably her
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one